[Musique]
vous vous êtes procuré le rapport c'est
en cours à le times détient sept mille
pages qui raconte en détail 30 ans de
mensonges de la maison blanche sur la
guerre du vietnam on parle de divulguer
des secrets que le gouvernement garde
depuis des années c'est légal ça qu'est
ce que tu crois qu'on fait ici comme
métier mon droit ok tout le monde
s'inquiète de voir une femme à la tête
du journal
ils craignent que vous n'ayez pas le
cran de prendre les décisions difficiles
à retirer je vous remercie pour votre
franchise si on publie on comparaît
devant la cour suprême la semaine
prochaine s'était-il
nous pourrions tous finir en prison
nixon mobilisera toute la puissance de
la présidence
et s'il existe un moyen de détruire tu
peux être certaine qu'il ne trouvera je
te demande un conseil comme
la permission elle ne peut pas faire ça
l'héritage spirituel du journal est en
jeu si nous ne publions pas on se
rappelle dans le pays qui sera perdant
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire madame
g